I'm in the computer science building at the university.
You might wonder what's a chemistry professor doing here.
And the answer is that 30 years ago, I had a mad idea.
My children had just started playing computer games and I suddenly
thought, why don't we make computer games for chemistry?
I hired two school boys during the summer.
They made a floppy disc with the games on it,
just after that,
there was a conference of science teachers at Nottingham.
So I set up a little stall, selling the computer disks.
My children were sitting in my office. Do you?
Plicating the desks as fast as they could.
And I was selling them for two pounds each and I got so much money in my
pockets that they pockets gave away money, pulled that down.
My trouser legs. It's the only time I've earned real cash for the university.
And for 30 years I had the discs in my filing cabinet
and every so often they looked at it, nostalgically, convinced.
I would never see the games again. And then a few weeks ago,
Steve Bagley from the computer.
Science came to my office and I showed him this desk and he
said, I might be able to make it work. I have an old computer.
So now I'm here in computer science to go to Steve's office
to see if I can play the games from this desk on the computer.
I know in Steve Bagley's office in a computer science
department, here is a BBC ma crew or BBC master.
Well, this computer I spent too much money on eBay probably is the best.
Now I like collecting or computers.
Those of you who see me on computer file will probably see my collection.
I can see. So these are like a rarity like hen's teeth or operating.
BBC's pretty common stuff. So I think most BBC micros are pretty common.
These still these days they're in a lot of schools.
So it's still a lot that survived. People collect them.
There was still a news controlling the sort of timetable displays on British
railway stations of a dealer a few years ago. Steve,
when someone gives you an old desk, what were you thinking?
Like you've got no chance with a like that. It depends how it's been stored.
Fortunately, Martin gave me, looked in pretty pristine condition,
but in his filing cabinet, sorry, I was pretty hopeful that it would work.
The dangers really are that it's been too hard.
It's been in a magnetic field or something, and it's wiped the information.
Sometimes the disc degrading or you get mold growing on them.
But generally as long as you've still got the media and confined a drive that
still works to play it. And you can usually try and get something off for years,
you will be able to see the damage if not had, I've forgotten how to start.
Okay. So, um, I was the first season, put it into the district,
which is just put it in drive, not push it in.
And then the little flat, Oh, it's sort of like, they see you use your ways.
You hold down shift and press the brake key in the let go brake.
And it starts up.
This is a sound.
Computer was a lot more visceral in those days they made noises and they sort
of, you heard them going. So.
It's not quite centered on the screen, but.
Yeah, the monitor for the BBC micro died.
So I had to wire up a little circuit to plug it into my guitar.
We won for terms.
This is the welcome screen for our video games.
The disc that you've actually got was they've got here,
was sponsored by the pharmaceutical company that then pharmaceutical companies
black.
So who made enough desks so that we could send one to every
school in the country.
And the picture shows a stylized picture of a university campus.
This is meant to be the chemistry department and some people boating on the
Lake. And this is the tower where the computer science used to be though,
when this was written, there wasn't a computer science department.
It was still taught in maths, Martin, what was your,
you haven't seen this for a while.
I wanted to feel like seeing it pop up on the screen. Wonderful. I mean,
it's like going back to my youth nearly 30 years, Steve,
more critical first impression.
I think I was going back to my youth.
It was being a school kid then sort of getting software like this to play.
I don't think I've ever used this when I was doing my chemistry level,
but I certainly saw things similar to this. So yeah.
Eight brought back moments for me as well.
We have to press the, any key.
So we have three games here, periodic table,
multiple choice and chemistry, Nottingham the information on the courses.
I don't think we need to look at the chemistry, knotting them at the moment.
No one. I want multiple choice.
Okay. Let's go.
Which should we try?
Perhaps we begin by displaying the full periodic table just to see what happens.
Yeah.
So should we try seeing, yeah.
Let's have a look at Silicon.
Silicon locate course.
And then, um, hit question Mark.
Well.
It's quite tight, Nicole, isn't it.
And that's gold.
I think, I think they've cheated.
I think they've got the same thing for quite a few elements here.
Perhaps they were running out to storage.
I want to see what it says for France.
Doesn't have very much on front SIM, but it has.
There's is a game where you get to fill in the blanks on the periodic table.
That'd be number two. I think
so there's three user defined tables,
but we've never randomly blank tables go on. For.
What percentage do you think?
Well, I think we got too high.
It'll take forever to do this and the video will go on longer than Dave
Brailsford. So let's go for about 5% or so six. Okay. We'll be adventurous.
6% is blank and 120 seconds that's given.
Well, there's a blank in the first room if I can find the cursor.
So that should be quite easy. That's carbon. Yep.
I knew that one. And then under
10 is late and Timmy's bespoke good
routine in the Russian element. And then also,
and then this is
[inaudible]. I think that one's red, the full temp. Was it red before Tinder,
but L w those Lorenz may have changed since then. What numbers, what numbers on
starting and that's 99, isn't it? 19 930 seconds left. It's not Curium Sippel
we'll have happen. You got five out of seven and 111 seconds. You score 232 hits
space for the full team. This is the best part.
So I didn't, I didn't make it.
You're not in the periodicity hall of fame professor.
You want to end the period in city hall of fame.
I don't know the reason they've had this chance to play these games is because I
was talking to Steve, who is a star of one of our other channels,
computer file about computing. And he had the computer.
I had the desk and bingo, but he can't do the games.
And if you want to watch computer file, there'll be links on screen.
And there are links in the video description as well,
and their opportunities to try and play this game online as well.
If you really want.
I then copied them via floppy disk onto my Mac,
using the floppy drive over here can then
I can use a BBC emulator. How many can you run at the same time?
Um, quite a lot. In fact, though,